miranda lambert gets emotional on her  keeper of the flame tour stop in Tinley  Park Illinois the country crooner was  brought to tears on stage at the  Hollywood Casino amphitheater Friday  while singing over you a song she  co-wrote with her ex-husband Blake  Shelton they see Albie okay  plenty of fans in the audience cried  with the singer as she sang the former  couples 2012 duet while we're not  certain what spark Miranda's waterworks  it's clear that duet set her off but she  also got teary eyed while belting out  lyrics to her hit the house that built  me prompting the crowd to sing along and  help her get through the touching lyrics  that could just come in I swear I leave  we  you